we begin with the border standoff that
turned violent today clashes broke out
at an eu border checkpoint when polish
forces used water cannon and tear gas to
push back migrants attempting to enter
from belarus
the european union has approved more
sanctions against the belarusian
government to punish it for creating
this crisis the eu accuses belarus of
trafficking potential asylum seekers
from the middle east to the border with
poland
an outburst of violence after days of
mounting tension polish authorities say
they fired water cannon and tear gas
after migrants threw stones and
attempted to destroy a fence
hundreds have massed at this closed
crossing just some of the several
thousand stranded on the belarus poland
border in freezing temperatures
their frustration expressed with each
hurled stone
it is night night it is night night we
here sleep
in forest in cold in hungary
we're waiting to urapa open way
but them not let anyone to help us have
them give us
gas and puppy
we will give them stone
the polish reaction gave the russian
foreign minister a chance to lecture the
european union about human rights
absolutely the behavior of the polish
side is unacceptable
i think the water cannon the tear gas
and shots over the migrants heads
towards belarus
all of it reflects a desire to hide
their own actions
and they must understand that they are
violating all thinkable norms of
international and humanitarian
law the situation escalates so too does
the diplomacy belarusian leader
alexander lukashenko held a call with
german chancellor angela merkel claiming
he doesn't want confrontation
the problem is that if we don't save
these people we will both lose
both belarus and to an even bigger
extent the european union
which doesn't let the refugees through
to its territory
that is why we need to urgently make a
decision about them
the eu and its allies blame belarus for
sparking a crisis eu defense ministers
met in brussels with nato raising the
prospect of a military response of
course we are deeply concerned about the
way the lukashenko regime is using
vulnerable migrants as a hybrid tactic
against other countries and this is
actually
putting
the life of the migrants at risk
and this is the human cost at least 11
people have died in recent weeks the
latest a 19 year old syrian man who
drowned trying to cross a river into the
eu
laid to rest by members of poland's
small muslim community
they say they fear he won't be the last
migrant they have to bury
and for more on this i'm joined now by
our correspondent terry schultz she's
following events for us from brussels
good evening to you terry we have seen
the most violence the most violent
clashes in this border standoff so far
today
what has been the reaction from the
european union
well brent perhaps not surprisingly the
eu and nato are much less vocal about
violations of human rights in their own
member countries than they are in others
these pictures must be making eu and
nato officials very uncomfortable
poland's actions of course are not what
anyone would like to see from an from an
eu country but at the same time uh
everyone in in this town in brussels uh
remains unified behind the message that
it was belarus that caused this
situation and never mind that now it's
the migrants on the other end of the
water cannons um the the blame remains
on minsk and that's the message they're
sticking to so far i wouldn't doubt and
i would even hope that some private
messages are being passed to the polish
government asking them to to
be be judicious in their in their use of
strong armed tactics like that i mean
for one reason as you heard foreign
minister lavrov it certainly gives
russians and other adversaries something
to talk about you say the blame
remains on minsk and yet we heard that
the leader of belarus lukashenko had a
phone call with the german chancellor
angela merkel yesterday did that
conversation did it raise a few eyebrows
in the european union
it did i i
angel america did tell the other eu
leaders that she was going to make this
call so it didn't didn't come as a
surprise they didn't find it out about
it in the headlines but for example um
some estonian politicians said this was
the wrong way to handle this no eu
leader has spoken with lukashenko since
august 2020 since those disputed
elections when the eu agreed with the
opposition that lukashenko had stolen
the election that he wasn't a legitimate
leader so no one else has bestowed this
legitimacy upon him of giving him a
phone call until
chancellor merkel so at the moment i
think that people are waiting waiting to
see if any good comes out of this call
but as i said there are people who think
that no one in on this side of that
border should be speaking with alexander
lukashenko at the moment yeah it is
interesting that the german chancellor
spoke with alexander lukashenko when
this crisis was erupting the first
person that merkel phoned was the
russian president vladimir putin all of
this begs the question tonight terry
does the european union does it have a
clear plan
on how to bring this crisis to an end
you know we've spoken about this several
times brent and the plan that the eu is
putting in place does seem to be having
some effect you know the first thing
that they were they're doing this week
is to go directly to capitals and ask
them to stop the flights stop people
from getting on the flights to add to
people
piling up at the borders there and in
fact we have seen airlines in iraq in
syria in qatar the uae in turkey many of
these hubs are now saying they will no
longer allow people to get on flights to
mints because it's obvious that uh
they're going to come to no good end
there that doesn't solve the problem of
the people who are now on the border the
people that we're seeing now in this you
know tug of war between belarus and
poland and it really isn't clear now how
this will turn out these people have to
go somewhere before they can be
repatriated if that's going to be how
the countries handle it but at the
moment it's getting very cold and
they're in a very very difficult
position
our correspondent terry schultz with the
latest tonight from brussels terry as
always thank you
and i'm joined now by olga rindova she
is the editor of the belarus analysis
it's good to have you on the program
let's look at what's happening on the
border right now is belarus
now at war with the european union a
great war that is taking place on its
border and the weapons that it's using
are refugees
well i'm not sure we can call it a war
anyway it's a kind of a method of
blackmailing the european union and
there are at least three uh aims that
lukashenka might trying to reach
first he's trying to um
more or less split the european union
that it doesn't speak with one voice and
the second is um
well he might try to get back his
international legitimacy that he lost in
august last year and
obviously also to some kind um well to
shift a focus so to save from the human
rights violations inside of galleries to
some other topics like migration on the
well migration crisis on the border
between belarus and poland
um
these are the aims of him and i i should
say that some of them have more or less
been reached i mean
we're now talking about the crisis on
the borders we're talking less about the
the political situation in belarus and
he also
spoke to merkel on the phone
and by the belarusian state media he was
presented as kind of
acceptance of his legitimacy but we
still see at the same time that the
european union is at least trying to
speak up with one voice and
help uh poland in this situation so i
don't think we should expect that the
sectoral sanctions that were introduced
a couple of months ago against belarus
they would be abolished because of this
crisis i think this is more or less the
hope in minsk
a few days ago
belarus threatened to to block or to
stop all gas flowing across its
territory into western
europe
do you see that threat
that decision as one that is being
supported by
russian president vladimir vladimir
putin i mean lukashinko says that but
would he be saying that if he didn't
have the backing of the kremlin
well we don't really know
where this plan uh of a migration crisis
comes from whether it comes from minsk
or from moscow we just don't have facts
for that but uh from the other hand we
understand that without an acceptance uh
of moscow this would not have been
happening right now so i think even it
was not their plan at least um
there is still some red line that has
not been reached by lukashenko for the
russian president at the same time i
don't really think
that it's an interest of russia to
really uh become part of this military
escalation between belarus and the
european union since
russia has also some military
obligations towards belarus and we know
that poland is a member of nato so i
think it's just
observing with interest what well how
the european union can react to such a
crisis and what happens within the
european union but i think there's still
some redline that maybe has already been
reached because we know that merkel
talked to kashanka after she talked on
the phone uh with putin
yeah well the story is fluid we will see
where things develop olga rindova the
editor at the belarus analysis we
appreciate your insights tonight olga
thank you
thank you